[Music]
if evils going to try to do something
horrible evils going to do something
horrible
if suspect is deceased the threat of us
stop think to the quick and heroic
actions of those safety members inside
the church and we will not stand for it
in New York City we will never allow the
Jewish beauty starts with these little
things and it gets worse just saying
Navigon is being taken serious right now
what is important right now is to make
sure that we don't get into a cycle of
minorities blaming other minorities
mr. Thomas why did you do it an ugly
holiday weekend of religious violence
let's take a look at the recent timeline
of attacks in New York anti-semitic
attacks in New York two incidents on
December 23rd one December 24th then on
the 25th an Orthodox Jewish man was
chased down the street and punched in
the face on the 26th the Jewish mother
and her son were attacked by a woman who
yelled anti-semitic slurs and punched
the mother in the head then two
incidents on December 27th and then the
worst of them of them all a man entering
the home of a rabbi during a Hanukkah
celebration and he began stabbing people
we have some numbers in terms of the
National anti-semitic hate crimes
incidents from the anti-defamation
league 2016 1267 2017 it surged to 1986
2018 another high number 1879 2019
year-to-date 1347 although a
particularly ugly stretch in New York
recently let's bring in our panel Chris
Starr Wald is the politics editor here
at Fox News Karen Tumulty an opinion
writer for The Washington Post and Tom
Bevan RealClearPolitics co-founder and
president Tom your thoughts well
obviously very disturbing and good to
see the folks are bringing attention to
this and calling it out it's it's hard
to say when you look at these two
attacks the motivations of these people
and as people have said it's it's evil
and and in that sense there's not a lot
that can be done but certainly good to
focus attention on it
and do what whatever can be done to make
sure that these things do in fact get
tamp down it's good to see though the
numbers despite the fact that we had
this surge recently that they're coming
down Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
today it's really a religious violence
problem around the globe we have seen
increased any semitism around the world
we've all observed Christians under
threat in the Middle East in other parts
of the world as well the President Trump
has made a true pillar of America's
foreign policy religious freedom the
right of each of us to practice our
faith and the way that we desire to do
so Karen your thoughts well as a number
of Jewish leaders said today it's not
just the you know the total number of
anti-semitic attacks that they're seeing
but sort of the size and the
aggressiveness I mean we are you know a
year out from the horrific massacre at
the Tree of Life synagogue and again
it's you wonder everyone denounces them
but at what point are we going to sort
of spot these people before they carry
out these these horrific acts Chris your
thoughts it is the cheapest easiest
point of division for human beings right
after race that's the easiest one the
next point that you can get people you
can pull people apart is on their creed
that somebody believes this way and
another person believes the other it is
part of the human nature it will always
sadly be with us the question is how are
people of good faith the question is how
are decent people responding what is
that what what is the response and what
every American should be proud of is
that across the country in every corner
from every race color creed insect the
same answer comes forward that it's just
never acceptable it's just never
acceptable and it's totally on American
we had an incident yesterday to church
in the Fort Worth Texas area where gun
packing parishioners really stopped it
from being a whole lot worse Tom yeah I
mean this is the story that you hear
about you know the good guys with guns
and and thank goodness there were people
there because who knows how many other
people might have died had they not
taken action but back to Chris's point I
mean it is also sort of downside to this
unfortunately is that it immediately
becomes political and you know you saw
Bill DeBlasio and Eric's law will come
out and try and blame the president for
what happened in New York or this rising
you know tide of anti-semitic aid when
the president actually came out with a
pretty strong but for him I thought was
a very very strong aggressive statement
on this so unfortunately people are
gonna play politics with this as well we
have some sound we can play for you from
Governor Cuomo of New York they should
be prosecuted as domestic terrorists
because that's what they are and I want
this state to be the first state to have
a domestic terrorism law to express how
ignorant this is how intolerant it is
and how criminal it is Karen what about
that suggestion of domestic terrorism
prosecution again we we still don't know
some of the motivations here for
instance in Texas we are just learning
about the shooter but this was a man who
had apparently a rest record in three
states including for domestic violence
so again we need to sort of sort a out
you know what the actual motivations are
here before we start branding these
things another thing that President
Trump has talked about is using the
civil rights laws to to crack down on
this this on the you know there's
there's some appeal to that idea but
they're also people are worried Jewish
leaders are worried that you are sort of
singling out what is a religion and and
sort of branding it a race or a
nationality so there are just all kinds
of complicated issues that you start
wading into it on stuff and you call
this as a hate crime and that's and this
is terras the same thing is always true
people need people in these situations
either need to be institutionalized or
incarcerated or in some way stop in
advance calling it something afterwards
maybe help Andrew Cuomo win votes may
help Donald Trump win votes I don't know
but the solutions are the same whatever
you call them speaking of the president
let's play what he had to say about this
before this recent wave in New York my
executive order prohibits federal
funding to any college or university
that spreads promotes tolerates or
supports
anything having to do with anti-semitism
we will not permit anti-jewish bigotry
on our college campuses and if they want
to do that it's going to be extremely
costly it'll be amazing how quickly they
stop and here we are just at the end of
Christmas and at the end of the Chanukah
season dealing with a wave of religious
violence both against Christians and
then also against Jews in New York City